Ladies and gentlemen,
although important progress has been
made in recent years to reduce poverty
today,
one point 2 billion people are still in
extreme poverty.
Combating poverty means revisiting our
global development goals to ensure that
they respond to the day's needs and
realities.
Poverty is a multidimensional challenge
that impacts the wellbeing of citizens
in societies worldwide.
It goes beyond material deprivation,
affecting people's health,
their self esteem,
and their ability to participate in
society and connect with other people.
It also hampers development by reducing
society's capacity to innovate and
promote progress.
This is why our quest for ending poverty
calls for measures that go beyond the
income to address inequality,
sustainability,
inclusiveness,
and wellbeing.
Tonight's discussion will shed light on
what we can and must do to address one
of the most formidable challenges of the
21st century ending poverty completely
forever.
So let's dedicate all our efforts,
all our energy and all our expertise to
this most worthy undertaking.